- Tada!
- Wow, was ist das denn?
- Spezialitäten aus
verschiedenen Ländern.
Ihr müsst die Fähnchen zuordnen.
- Das ist ja einfach!
Also, Köttbullar …
isst man in Schweden! So.
- Warst du schon mal in Schweden?
- Nee, aber ich fahre
nächstes Jahr nach Norwegen!
- Nimmst du mich mit?
- Klar!
- Nawin? Du gehst nach Frankreich.
- In Frankreich isst man gern Käse.
- Ja, gar nicht so schlecht!
Und du, Sebastian?
- Hier, gib her.
So.
Also, Sushi isst man in Japan
und in Italien isst man Pizza!
- Super!
Und Nico, was isst man in Spanien?
- In Spanien isst man Gazpacho!
- Perfekt.
- Und du wohnst in Frankreich?
- Bald, ja.
Ich habe da einen Job.
- Cool …
- Na ja.
Ich mag Deutschland.
- Ich auch.